hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
right now i've got my property
developers hat on
because i've come to see a piece of land
now we've been speaking to the
owner over the phone matt leeds my
company along with my two brothers
we found it if we buy it we're gonna
project manage it
we're going to buy the land maybe it's a
joint venture but i always think it's
important to see on sea land in person
because you can see a lot about the area
so here's the land there's people
sniffing around like crazy interested so
i'm not going to tell you exactly where
i am
well you like it
anyway see you later
that's the thing when you get a piece of
land so beautiful as this
i mean literally while i've been filming
this video people driving up looking
asking what's going on is it for sale
what's happening and that's the problem
with good developments like this
i mean we're speaking directly with the
vendor on this but
i think if we're going to buy it we need
to put forward an offer we need to do it
quickly
what do you reckon here are the figures
if we buy for 200 000 pounds
here's how we're going to make profit
we're going to get planning permission
to build on it now there was planning
permission on this piece of land
but it lapsed it lapsed 10 years ago
and that was to build five apartments
which would probably be worth around
about two hundred thousand pounds each
which would give a gdv
gross development value of one million
pounds approximately
if we were to build five apartments now
if we buy the land for 200
it will probably cost us about 400 000
pounds to build the apartments
we've got a nice bit of profit in there
even after you take out contingency and
professional fees
there's no problem with um access
it's all good if we don't get planning
for five apartments
i am very very confident i know the
planning consultants in the area i know
what the area are looking to do
i'm not going to name the area but i'm
very confident we'll be able to build
two semi-detached houses and why i'm
confident is because
it's all about when you're looking at
can you get planning permission for
something it's all about is it fitting
with the area
now will we get apartments i don't know
10 years ago there was planning for
apartments there is an apartment block
just
just behind this site and there are
semi-detached houses all leading up to
this site so
would it be fitting to build two
semi-attached houses here and the answer
is yes
because all down the street it's two
semis two semis
two semis then this nice big piece of
land it wouldn't be unattractive
it would be fitting and in keeping with
the area so
now if we bought it for cash without
planning
the money's in the planning so that's a
good thing but there's a risk we
wouldn't get planning
so the way i'm going to propose to the
owner that we buy this is we get an
option agreement and an option agreement
means
when you basically you have the option
to buy the land at a later date
we could get an option agreement to buy
in six months it'll give us six months
to be able to get the planning
permission
get everything all good so hopefully the
owner will be open to that but we'll see
what happens so
i'm gonna keep you posted on what
happens with this site i'm gonna put
forward an offer
fingers crossed we're gonna get it
wrapped up i'll document it for the
journey i'm not gonna say where it is
but maybe you know if you recognize this
piece of land or if you think you know
what city i'm in
comment below where do you think i am
and i'll let you know
very very soon if we buy this land so
let me know
i'm really i really like it it's a great
area and
i'm going to be documenting the whole
journey of my development journey as
always
my property investment journey i'll be
documenting my students journeys
if you want to learn more about property
development land
investment then subscribe to the channel
you can do that right here
if you want to see a previous project
where i built six houses from scratch
and made a profit between us of half a
million pounds
check that video out right here and i
look forward to seeing you next time see
you soon